bonsoir merci d'être avec nous ce soir
alexis poullan et l'elysée a lancé un
discours d'unité d'espoir et de vérité
ce que c'est réussi selon alors selon
moi non c'est un ratage complet il
faudrait expliquer à blesle mâcon qu'il
est président de la république et pas
télévangéliste ce que j'ai vu ce soir
m'a scandalisé tout simplement ce n'est
pas des voeux d'un président c'était une
histoire une histoire racontée ou pas du
feu d'ailleurs où emmanuel macron
inventé enfin où on reprenait ce des
personnages ces français qu'il ne
connaît pas ac il dit merci maintenant
après les avoir traités de tous les noms
pendant trois ans gaulois réfractaires
séditieux factieuses que vous voulez les
voilà maintenant essentiel à la bonne
marche de ce pays
et le voilà choisissant des destins
français pour faire croire qu'il connaît
ce pays qu'il m
alors que finalement ce qu'on a vu
c'était beaucoup de violences s'étaient
beaucoup d'heureux j'ai beaucoup aussi
d'incompréhension et la vérité elle
n'existe pas c'est des faisceaux de
vérité ça va être très compliqué d'y
arriver mais là il ya un conteur au coin
du feu qui se racontent une histoire à
lui même c'est assez triste
j'ai trouvé que jouer sur la passion de
cette façon là ne pas parler de bilan de
l'action du gouvernement sur cette crise
sanitaire qui était catastrophique
depuis mars
il faut rappeler ce soir puisque
emmanuel macron ne l'a pas fait le
scandale des masques le scandale des
tests qui ont été mal fait et le
scandale de cette vaccination à 5
vaccins par jour quand nos voisins sont
à dix mille par jour
voilà la réalité voilà la réalité et
voilà la vérité d'une certaine façon et
c'est ce que nous dit emma de macron
c'est bravo vous pouvez être fiers
d'être français c'est super et jamais
jamais il ne parle de son bilan de ce
qu'il a fait mais il nous raconte une
histoire une histoire à laquelle peu de
gens croient maintenant aujourd'hui je
crois que c'est un moment assez
dystopique que nous vivons en train à
préfet de police comme didier lallement
qui seat leon trotsky entre un président
qui avant des héros nationaux et qui
pointe du doigt les conspirationnistes
les complotistes
on est dans un no man's land quelque
part ou où je ne comprends plus ce qui
se passe puisque il veut en fait
raccrocher les wagons avec le peuple
français le président a embastillé
cachez bunkerisé à l'e10 est derrière
des rangées de crs veut faire croire
qu'il connaît ce peuple qu'il aime ce
pays parce qu'il en a besoin bien sûr
pour 2022 il nous remet encore une
couche façon télévangéliste ans sur le
printemps sur la renaissance sur cette
envie que nous avons de refaire les
choses ensemble ils parlent de pays uni
je sais pas s'il a vu le nombre de
manifestations
les français inquiets des lois
liberticides qui ont été à l'ordre du
jour pendant des mois avec cette
majorité poussé par l'exécutif avec des
lois décrets
on a l'impression qu'il vit ailleurs
qu'en france qu'il vit dans un autre
pays et que ce qu'il a fait ce soir
c'était raconter son pays celui qu'il
aimerait voir celui qu'il aimerait qu'il
soit et ça c'est typique des modèles
macron c'est à dire qu'il est dans cette
narration de la start up nation dans
cette narration aussi dans cette
histoire permanente
il nous raconte des histoires or cette
histoire je crois qu'il est le seul à y
croire avec quelques-uns de ces derniers
fans à 23% on va dire à peu près ce qui
était au premier tour sont toujours là
mais ça ne marche pas un roman national
s'il doit s'écrire et doit s'écrire avec
le peuple il doit s'écrire au pluriel et
pas avec la plume aussi brillante soit
elle d'un seul au coin du feu
il était aussi attendu emmanuel macron
sur la situation sanitaire notamment
après s être polémique sur la lenteur de
la vaccination il n'en a pour ainsi dire
dit aucun mot quasiment pas parce
qu'encore une fois il s'agit de cacher
les manquements les erreurs les
mensonges les ratages de ce gouvernement
il s'agit de faire croire que la france
est un des pays qui a le mieux géré
cette épidémie il s'agit de faire croire
qu'il est un des présidents qui a le
mieux géré on le voit aussi alors qu'ils
touchent sur la corde sensible sur
l'émotion à aucun moment il ne parle lui
de son voyage de la façon dont il a
attrapé une coronavirus il faisait des
celles-ci il ya quinze jours à la
lanterne 1 pour expliquer qu'il était
très malade
las il n'en sait même pas allusion il
parle des français parce qu'il voudrait
faire croire qu'il est altruiste et que
oui nous avons besoin de nous mais non
aujourd'hui et je le redis nous avons
simplement a constaté un l'allumage de
la campagne de vaccination qui n'est pas
lui mais jean castex promettait il y a
trois semaines quinze jours 1,16 million
de doses de vaccins on en est même pas à
10000 on a vacciné en
on 200 français se sait comment c'est
acceptable comment peut-on encore croire
à la parole des malades macron de son
gouvernement
croire que cela gouverne que cela gère
cette épidémie quand ils ne font qu
improvisé et mal et je leur disais le
scandale des masques rappelez vous quand
ils riaient au nez des commentateurs
politiques parce qu' il fallait ne pas
mettre des masques parce que c'est
inutile
rappelez-vous la façon dont les tests
n'ont pas été faites de manière efficace
l'été il était sur son jet skis les
français avaient le droit d'aller en
vacances tout allait bien la seconde
vague n'arriverait pas seconde vague
arrive et puis voilà finalement qu'on en
est avec ce vaccin qui promet et quelque
chose m'inquiète aussi dans ce discours
c'est la place de l'espoir
finalement du tout dans le derrière
plusieurs reprises un l'espoir est là il
promet d'ailleurs pour 2021 d'inventer
une économie plus forte je le cite
oui alors une économie qui va être une
tête catastrophique
une économie qui va faire de nombreuses
faillites puisque des secteurs entiers
sont confinés depuis des mois et voilà
que lui nous parle d'espoir il est
encore une fois dans un rôle non pas de
président non pas de quelqu'un qui xam
qui prend à bras le corps un pays et qui
va aider ce pays
il est dans le rôle d'un télévangéliste
qui vous vend du rêve de l'espoir de la
croyance de la foi dans le progrès ce
progressisme qu'il a promis déjà en 2017
je crois qu'on peut juger sur pièce ça
fait trois ans on a vu qu entre les
paroles et les actes
il y à un fossé et que rien ne raccroche
les deux et dans ce discours de ce soir
c'est vraiment de la désillusion c'est
quelque chose propre à emmanuel macron
c'est à dire qu'il invente un récit qui
n'a rien à voir avec notre réalité ce
que nous vivons aujourd'hui en france et
vous l'avez dit il évite soigneusement
de parler de ce qui fâche tout ce qui a
raté dans cette gestion de crise il faut
remplir quand le 10 mars est venu mike
tombe wii uniquement un mot le 10 mars
emmanuel macron rappelait que les
français et les françaises qui auront le
corps d'un virus auront une forme
bénigne pour 85% d'entre eux et c'est le
cas et c'est toujours le cas
or aujourd'hui on a l'impression que ce
virus est la seule cause de mortalité en
france puisqu'il a rappelé 4000 victimes
du corps d'un viol oui mais combien de
victimes du cancer
combien de victimes d'autres maladies
combien de victimes d'accidents de là
tout ça on n'en parle pas c'est le corps
n'a virus qui doit uniquement occupé nos
pensées et c'est là où je parle de
récits décisionnel on n'est pas du tout
dans la vérité dans la transparence
promise
on est dans une histoire que nous
raconte mails macron pour préparer sa
candidature de 2022 et pour moi ça fait
ça ne marche pas et voilà pour l'analyse
de notre un éditorialiste à l'équipe
oullins